[inaudible] and violence cannot be
assessed by headlines.
Headlines are about things that happen
and they give you no indication
whatsoever of how common a particular
activity as a cause.
You'd never see reporter standing
outside a school saying,
I,
here I am in front of the Maplewood high
school,
which hasn't been shot up today.
Uh,
or here I am in the capital of
Mozambican.
There's no civil war.
So forget headlines.
You have to,
the only way to answer the question of
what are the trends in violence is to
look at data where you count the number
of occurrences as a proportion of the
number of opportunities.
And you see whether that's changed over
time.
So since I wrote better angels of our
nature,
and,
uh,
I sent it off to the press in,
end of 2010.
So the data that were available from
Warfarin,
oh eight,
oh nine,
uh,
I keep yearly updates on what's happened
to those trends.
And with the exception of civil war,
which after a rollercoaster downward
from the end of World War II has shown
something of an uptick,
uh,
because of the Syrian civil war,
it's wiped out about 13 years of
progress taking us back to the level of
luck,
2000 white,
it's still a fraction of the level that
it was at in the 60s,
70s and 80s,
when you had not just,
uh,
eight or nine civil wars going on at a
time,
but a 25 or 30,
uh,
we,
we tend to forget them.
We tend to be amnesic about,
uh,
all those nasty wars in Africa and
Southeast Asia that were going on in
the,
in the seventies and eighties.
But a lot of them had a considerable
death tall.
So it's clearly things have gotten worse
in,
in Syria.
They've gotten worse in Ukraine and,
uh,
and um,
Pakistan,
but the global trend has not,
uh,
reverse the progress that we have seen
by any means.
Then all the other trends such as
homicide,
which kills far more people than wars,
uh,
continues to go down.
Sexual violence,
at least in countries that have good
data,
have continued to go down.
Rape and domestic violence.
Child abuse has continued to go down
more and more states and countries have
abolished capital punishment,
even democratization of government.
The absence of government violence where
we're aware of backsliding in countries
like Venezuela and that Turkey and
Russia,
but still the global trend continues to
beat that the world is getting more
democratic.
We don't read about the countries that
have liberalized,
but we hear about the countries that are
increased their repression and that they
do exist.
But on the whole,
the world has become more democratic as
well as less homicidal,
uh,
less,
um,
uh,
gender based violence,
less child abuse and so on.
And,
um,
even in the category of war,
you can divide wars into wars between
countries.
Old fashioned wars of country,
a declares war on country B and civil
wars.
And,
uh,
the first category,
interstate wars,
uh,
government on each side has been in,
um,
kind of sputtering decline for many
decades.
Uh,
there are and fewer wars between
countries.
The wars that exist are civil wars and,
um,
that has,
uh,
that record has continued to,
to,
um,
uh,
to,
to improve.
Uh,
namely,
we've had zero interstate wars since the
better angels of our nature was
published.
And in fact,
we've had zero interstate wars since the
American invasion of Iraq in 2003.
And historically,
wars between countries tend to kill more
people than civil wars.
So even with the backsliding that we've
seen in,
uh,
in the case of civil war,
in the case of the most destructive form
of wars,
the world is still not seeing a return
today.
The battle days of the seventies and
eighties.